Make a joyful noise unto the Lord, all
ye lambs. Serve the Lord with gladness.
Come before his presence with singing.
Know ye that the Lord, he is God. It is
he that hath made us, and not we
ourselves. We are his people, and the
sheep of his pasture. Enter into his
gates with thanksgiving, and into his
courts with praise. Be thankful to him
and bless his name for the Lord is good.
His mercy is everlasting and his truth
endureth to all generations. God is good
>> all the time
>> and all the time.
>> And we just read verse five of Psalm
100. For the Lord is good.
His mercy is everlasting, and his truth
endureth to all generations.
>> As long as there was God, there was
truth. As long as there is God, there is
truth. As long as there will be God,
there will be truth.
>> Because God himself is truth. Jesus
says, "I am the truth." And first John
5:6, the Holy Ghost is truth. In order
to be a member of the heavenly family,
you and I must be a people of truth.
>> Because the father, the son, and the
holy spirit are truth. And Jesus tells
us, they that worship God must worship
him how? In spirit and in truth. And
verse 23 of John chapter 4 tells us,
"The father seeketh such to worship
him." He is looking for those who will
worship him based on truth.
>> Good afternoon.
>> How are you?
>> Thank you for the music, my handsome
brother, but Peter's. God bless you.
Bless you. Bless you. I really mean that
sincerely. I look forward to hearing
Jesus sing.
And the angels sing
>> and the redeemed stand on the sea of
glass and sing.
>> And when that happens, I'll try to sing
softly so I don't sing any bad notes.
But I look forward to hearing singing in
heaven.
>> There will be singing up in heaven such
as we have never heard.
>> You know, there's nothing to lose heaven
for on this earth.
You lose a life with no sickness,
>> no death,
>> no pain,
>> no war,
>> no political elections.
>> A life of bliss.
>> Now, this is not pie in the sky. This is
literal. A life lived in the very
presence of God who now is a consuming
fire.
A life lived as you walked down some
street in the new Jerusalem with the
angel that protected you from a thousand
dangers
>> and who is with you right now but we
cannot see him.
>> A life in which you fellowship with
Abraham.
>> You have lunch with Noah
>> uh and you hang out with Moses.
>> How do you miss that?
>> Because of a cigarette.
You miss that for alcohol.
Ah, come on. Even sinners should have a
little more common sense than that. Who
is with us this afternoon? You weren't
here this morning. May I see your hands?
God bless you. God bless you. Where are
you from?
Where
[Music]
>> Plymouth Sarrento
>> in Apopka? God bless that church family.
Thank you for anybody else. What church
are you from?
>> A popka sda.
Any other church? Yes, sister.
Say that loudly.
The French church Baraka
>> in popku.
>> Baraka French church.
>> Okay. All right.
>> What's it called?
>> Baraka.
>> Isn't that blessing in Swahili?
>> Okay. All right. Any other church?
>> Shiloh. Where is that?
>> Okala. How far is that from a popka?
>> Hour and a half. Well, we thank God for
bringing you safely. May he take you
back safely.
>> Let me uh Yes.
>> Stateline SDA in Ardmore, Alabama.
>> Stateline SDA in Ardmore, Alabama. Now,
how far is that?
>> 10 hours. 9 hours. Okay. Sounds like
Abraham going to sacrifice Isaac. Okay.
Yes. Sister, where you from?
>> Miami Temple.
>> Miami Temple. Where's that?
>> Miami Temple. In Miami. In Miami, how
long how far away is that?
>> Three and a half. Okay. All right.
Florida is longish but not wide.
>> Well, except for the top. Then you
stretch all the way to the west. Okay.
What nationalities are present?
>> Okay. One at a time. We don't want a
civil war or any where the
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Elsa.
>> Panama. God bless Panama. Any other
Panameanians?
Okay. All right. I have a friend,
childhood friend. He is from He lives in
Panama, but originally from Barbados.
All right. Beside Panama, who?
>> Barbados.
>> Oh, that's where all the saints are.
Okay.
>> El Salvador.
>> Okay. Yes, sister.
>> Where?
>> Salvador.
>> El Salvador. God bless El Salvador. Yes.
Yes, sister.
>> Puerto Rico. I have landed in Puerto
Rico a couple of times but just changed
planes. Never got out. God bless Puerto
Rico.
>> From Colombia, South America.
>> Where?
>> Colombia, South America.
>> Colombia. I have a brother, spiritual
brother who has a home in Colombia.
Never been there.
>> Any other nationality?
>> Jamaica.
>> Where is Jamaica?
>> Back over here.
>> Okay. No, this isn't Jamaica. This is
This isn't a popka. This is Kingston.
Okay. All right. It's Yeah. God bless
Jamaicans.
One of my favorite foods is aki. Oh boy.
I ah I love a capital L. All right. Any
other nation?
>> St. Lucia.
>> Oh, my parents are from St. Lucia. Who's
from St. Lucia?
>> Who's from St. Lucia?
>> What I told her is between her and me.
None of your business. All right. And
what other what other country?
>> Brazil.
>> Haiti.
>> Well, you have a pat similar to St.
Lucia. All right. God bless Haiti. Yes,
sister.
>> Where?
>> Guyana. I was in Guyana about 10 years
ago. I have good friends.
The pastors of my local churches have
been Gy. A succession of Gy pastors. I
have good friends from Guyana. All
right. Yes, sister.
>> Trinidad.
>> Trinidad. I have a clo I have close
friends from Trinidad. I've only been
there once. Yes.
>> Young lady,
>> Brazil.
>> Brazil. I was in Brazil last year. I
landed in Sa Paulo and they drove me six
hours into the country where I had to
speak. I thought I was going to another
country. Okay.
>> One more. Yes.
>> Iberian
>> Sor.
>> Where?
>> Plymouth, Saranto.
>> What?
>> Is that a country?
>> Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. I'm asking for countries.
Never heard of Plymouth of Sarrento.
Okay. Yes, my brother.
>> Uh, Iberian, Spaniard, Portuguese.
>> Oh, I was in Spain last year. I flew
into Malaga. Then they drove me 5 hours
into the mountains and uh I was there
for a few days. God bless Spain.
>> Grenada.
>> Yes, sister.
>> St. Vincent. I never been there. I have
friends from St. Vincent. Are you from
the Mesopotamia Valley? Close by St.
Vincent. All right. God bless St.
Vincent.
>> Yes.
>> Greece.
>> Greece. I've never been to Greece. Very
historic country. I must go. Yes. All
right. Okay. I'll tell God you told me
to go. Okay.
>> Yes.
>> Grenada.
>> Grenada is a good place. I have I think
I have some friends from Grenada. The
spice island of Grenada. All right. Yes.
>> The Commonwealth of the Bahamas.
>> The Commonwealth of the Bahamas. I was
in Nassau about 10 years ago preaching.
I enjoyed it particularly because the
church was close to the beach. Okay.
Anyone? Yes.
Ah, United States of America. All right.
Yes. The lamblike beast. Okay.
It's not my words. You got to blame God,
not me.
God bless the lamb. Okay. Oh, yes,
sister.
>> Happy Sabbath. Mexico.
>> Mexico. I've been to Tijuana once. Long
time before you were born. Long time
ago. All right. Any other country?
>> So, if America is a lamblike me beast,
what is Turkey?
>> Turkey.
>> To live in Turkey.
>> Oh, I don't know what Turkey is, but are
you from Turkey?
>> Sort of. Are you serious?
>> Turkey.
>> You from Turkey?
Jamaican.
>> Oh, you're Jamaican living in Turkey.
Okay. All right.
I've never heard of Aki and Turkey, but
that's okay.
Ai and Sfish, not Aki and Turkey. Okay.
Anybody else? Any other country? God
bless all the countries. Did we exhaust?
Okay.
Uh, I didn't hear Guadaloop. I didn't
hear Martineique. I didn't hear St.
I didn't hear Antigga.
>> I didn't hear Dominica.
>> Did I hear St. Yes, I heard St. Lucia.
That's where my parents are from. Okay.
God is good
>> all the time
>> and all the time.
>> What time is sunset?
>> Who has to rush off to work?
>> Who has to rush off to work before the
sun sets? Nobody. Okay.
All right.
Who's with us? Who's not a Seven of the
Adventist?
And I have not yet met you.
Anyone?
All right. Well, thank God for your
presence. Let's try to get into the
word. As always, I have three little
favors. They're not grievous. If you're
not using one of these things, please
turn them off completely. If you are
using them, turn the sound all the way
down so that God is not disturbed. God
is very serious about reverence.
Even more serious than earthly judges.
When you sit in a courtroom, you know
you behave.
You're in front of a sinful earthly weak
judge and you behave. You don't text.
You don't joke. You don't drink orange
juice or Kool-Aid. You don't do any of
that in the courtroom because that judge
will put you in your place with bars.
Are you following me? We're in the
presence of the judge of all the earth.
>> I won't have I won't say anything more.
Favor number two. While I'm speaking,
pray for me. And so, Lord, put your
words in that man's mouth. Jeremiah 1:9.
Then the Lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth. And the Lord said unto
me, behold, I have put my words in thy
mouth. Consider, God said, I'm putting
my words, those words are divine, in my
mouth, made of dirt,
divine, human, that I may deliver the
words of God. Exodus 4:12, God said to
Moses, "Now therefore, go. I will be
with thy mouth and teach thee what thou
shalt say." 2 Samuel 23:2,
"The spirit of the Lord spake by me and
his word was in my tongue."
>> I want God to put his words in my mouth.
>> My opinions cannot save you.
>> The words of God will transform your
lives. Favor number three, think as you
listen.
You are required by God to think. Are
you with me?
>> Let's pray.
Holy Father,
take possession of my mind,
my body.
I offer myself to you as an instrument.
Use me, dear God. I offer no resistance.
Forgive my sins.
Receive me now as I lean my full weight
upon you. Don't move, God. If you move,
I'll fall. Bless those listening in this
building and online. Let your spirit
whisper in my ear from time to time. You
are in this desk for the glory of God,
not for yours. Father, let the message
be simple enough for the children to
understand.
>> Touch the sick. Bless every country
represented by those listening, Father,
but particularly the host country of the
United States.
Keep us faithful to the end, Father.
That's literal. Keep us faithful to the
end.
>> Now, dear God, accept my thanks for the
high honor of speaking for you and the
secondary honor of speaking to your
beloved children. In Jesus name I pray.
Amen.
Go with me to Genesis chapter 1.
We read verse one. It is now 5 minutes
to
What time is it?
>> 3:26.
>> 3:24. Okay. Thank you. I'll release you.
Well, there's a Q&A right after this, so
I'm not sure when you'll release.
Genesis 1, we read from verse one.
I hear a lot of talking.
[Music]
Ah, that's better.
Okay.
Do you have Genesis 1:1?
>> Without reading your Bible, tell me what
it says.
>> In the beginning, God created the heaven
and the earth.
We shall reread that verse this time
microscopically.
In the beginning,
God
created
the heaven and the earth. When you read
heaven and earth, you must also include
everything in heaven and everything on
earth.
That verse presents to us, by the way,
it's my favorite verse. two levels of
existence.
You either exist as God
or you exist as a part of creation.
There is no other way to exist
or as far as we know. You either God or
you are part of creation.
Name the highest angel in heaven.
Gabriel, where does he belong?
Creation.
Pick a single cellled organism. Is the
amoeba a single cell organism for you
scientists?
Where does it belong?
>> Creation.
From an amoeba
to Gabriel.
Created.
The only ones who occupy God
is father, son, and holy ghost.
>> Every other thing that lives or simply
exists, animate or inanimate, falls
under created.
Genesis chapter 1, I always say, is
God's resume.
This is what I have done.
this is what I can do. Now, when you
apply for a position, you present a
resume or some people call it curriculum
viter and it lists all your astonishing
accomplishments
on nice paper
perfumed and nicely typed because you're
trying to make the right
>> impression.
God also wants to make the right
impression.
And so the Bible opens not with Calvary
but with creation
because one day there will be no more
need for praying and offering and but
there will always be the need for a
creator.
Long before sin there was no need for
savior. There was a creator. Are you
with me? In the new world, from one
Sabbath to another shall all flesh come
to worship before me, says God. We will
always have a creator
>> to sustain the heaven and the earth.
>> Amen.
>> In the beginning,
God, the source of all things. And as
we're told in Colossians 1:17, he is
before all things and by him all things
consist.
The question then arises,
how did he do that?
How did God make the heavens and the
earth?
We go to verse two and verse three of
Genesis 1.
our subject by every word.
And the earth was without form and void,
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep, and the spirit of God moved upon
the face of the waters. Verse three, and
God said, "Let there be light." And
there was light. And God saw the light
that it was good. And God divided the
light from the darkness. And God called
the light day and the darkness he called
night and the evening and the morning
were the first day. Question for you.
How was light created?
You're taking too long.
>> By the word. What's our subject?
>> Yeah. How did he do that? But by every
word. Verse six. And God said, "Let
there be a firmament in the midst of the
waters, and let it divide the waters
from the waters." And God made the
firmament, and divided the waters which
were under the firmament from the waters
which were above the firmament. And it
was so. And God called the firmament
heaven. And the evening and the morning
were the second day. Quiz question
number two. How was the firmament made?
By the word.
And God said, "Let the waters under the
heavens be gathered together unto one
place, and let a dry land appear." And
it was so. And God called the dry land
earth, and the gathering together of the
waters called. He sees how did God
perform that? By his word.
And we can go all the way down chapter
one. Day three, we complete day three
with God selling the earth bring forth
grass. God said creation was brought
about by the word.
That word you're holding in your hand.
I frequently say creation wasn't brought
about by paper and ink. It was brought
about by the word. Because long before
there was paper and ink, there was the
word. Are you with me? We're not
discussing something from a publishing
house. We're discussing something that
is personal. Why? John 1 verse one. In
the beginning was the word and the word
was with God and the word was God.
>> Amen.
>> The same was in the beginning with God.
All things were made by him and without
him was not anything made that was made.
Verse 14 tells us, "And the word became
flesh and dwelt among us."
>> Jesus Christ.
How did he do it? By his word,
having made the universe and the earth.
That's creation.
Something made has to be sustained
>> or it'll collapse. Are you with me?
Something made has to be sustained. Go
to second. Let's go to Hebrews chapter
1. We read from verse one.
By every word
chapter 1, reading from verse one.
If ever I go too quickly, and I do it
very often, just say slow down. And I'll
feel very privileged and blessed that
you would say that.
Do you have Hebrews chapter 1 reading
from chapter reading from verse one? God
who at sunundry times and in diverse
manners spake in time past unto the
fathers by the prophets hath in these
last days spoken unto us by his son whom
he hath appointed heir of all things.
Read with me now. By whom also he made
the world. So we have creation done by
Jesus Christ at the direction of the
father. You see, Christ is the agent in
creation. He did it for the father. He's
also the father's agent in salvation.
Verse three, we already have creation in
verse two. We go to verse three. Who
being the brightness of his glory and
the express image of his person. Read
with me now. And upholding all things.
What all things? Creation. In verse two,
by whom also he made the worlds. When
you read and made the worlds, you must
include heaven.
>> Upholding all things by the word of his
power. Now, let's put two and two
together.
See what we come up with. Come on in.
Come on in.
Verse two ends this way. By whom also he
made the worlds. That's creation. Verse
three says, Upholds all things upholding
creation by the word.
of his power.
Which means the word that creates
is the same word
>> that sustains.
If that's the case, it has always been
God's desire that the level of
excellence in creation will be
maintained
forever.
Uh God didn't use a lower word to
maintain.
>> Are you with me? He used the same
powerful word. And so he wanted creation
maintained at the level of its creation.
>> You know, you build a house today, next
week you need repairs. Mm-
>> Are you following me? God's desire was
it would continue at that level of
creation's excellence.
But sin entered the world
and sin affected everything.
So now what was absolutely excellent was
now contaminated.
Not by the word that came from God. It
was contaminated by a word that came
from somebody else whom his creatures
believed.
That sounds clumsy. Let me explain that
biblically. Go to Genesis 2.
We read 16 and 17 by every word. Genesis
2:16-17.
We just said creation was corrupted
by the word. But whose word
do you have? Genesis 2 16:17.
And the Lord God commanded the man,
saying, "Of every tree of the garden,
thou mayest freely eat, but of the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil, thou
shalt not eat of it. For in the day thou
eatest thereof, thou shalt surely die.
Now that was God's word.
Nothing confusing about that. You eat,
you die. Or to say the same thing
differently. You disobey, you die. Let's
fix it in our minds what God said. In
the day thou eatest thereof, thou shalt
surely die. Go to chapter 3 of the book
of Genesis. We'll read from verse one.
The Bible is a simple book largely.
All the essentials required for
salvation are simple as ABC.
Now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the Lord God
had made. And he said unto the woman,
"Yeah, hath God said, Ye shall not eat
of every tree of the garden."
Did God really say, "The seventh day is
the Sabbath?"
you. A question put in your mind causes
you to question yourself. That's why you
ought not to listen to some people at
all.
>> Are you with me? Just say, "Excuse me,
I've got to go." Don't listen to some
people at all. Because once something
gets into your head, you cannot get it
out.
>> Hath God said, "He shall not eat of
every tree of the garden?" And the woman
said unto the serpent, we may eat of the
fruit of the trees of the garden, but of
the fruit of the tree which is in the
midst of the garden, God hath said, he
shall not eat of it, neither shall he
touch it, lest she die. And the serpent,
verse four, said unto the woman, he
shall not surely die. That's a different
word.
following that word led to the
contamination of God's creation.
Verse five, for God doth know that in
the day you eat thereof, then your eyes
shall be opened and you shall be as
God's, knowing good and evil.
To repair the damage done by somebody
else's word, what do we have to do? Get
back to
>> original word.
>> Get back to the original word
>> which is what God said.
Now the same person the same person who
said you shall not surely die. The
person also said the first day of the
week is the Sabbath.
That person also said you can be
baptized by being christened.
That person also said it's okay to have
more than one wife.
That person also said uh alcoholism is
not a sin. That person also said it's
okay to work on the Sabbath if you have
children to support.
That person also said you can use the
tie for hospital emergency
because God is merciful.
To undo the damage done by someone
else's word which Adam and Eve followed,
we have to get back to what God said.
>> Amen.
>> That other being who said you shall not
surely die. He has told many of us and
we follow it. It's okay to be an
equalote.
And we call it boyfriend evangelism.
And it's not biblical because God told
the Israelites over and over, "They will
take you from me." Not once does he say,
"You will bring them to me."
>> He always warns the Israelites, "They
will take you from me." He never says,
"You will bring them to me."
The cure for the contaminated universe
is to get back to the word of God.
>> Verse six. And when the woman saw that
the tree was good for food, and that it
was pleasant to the eyes, and a tree to
be desired to make one wise,
sin makes nobody wise.
You can have a PhD in astrophysics,
a PhD in Aristotellian logic, and a PhD
in Platonic philosophy, and you do not
believe in God, the Bible says you're
fool.
>> With three PhDs, a fool.
>> No error. I don't know how error can be
scholarly.
You didn't get what I said. Men do PhDs
in theology and they say the B the Bible
did not really happen. It's just
allegory and symbolism. Uh there was no
creation of Adam and Eve and he gets a
PhD
>> and it's called an expert. God calls him
a fool.
Error cannot be scholarly.
>> Nobody's listening.
Well, you're processing. Ah, I'm glad to
hear that.
I'm glad to hear that. Mhm. I really am.
And when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eyes.
This person who said, "You shall not
surely die." He is a specialist at
marketing.
Regardless of the product you have to
sell, if you don't market it well, you
won't sell it.
You have to market it in such a way that
people looking at it feel I need that
>> even though it's death.
>> Are you with me?
>> So you can market death as a liquid
that celebrities drink then you feel
like a celebrity when you drink it. Are
you listening to me? You can market
death as something that goes between
your lips and you inhale and blow out
smoke and it makes you look cool as you
move towards the funeral home.
The devil markets death
attractively. When the woman saw that
the tree was good for food and that it
was pleasant to the eyes, what did
Samson tell his parents when he saw a
Philistine?
She pleases me.
>> She pleasth me well. He saw lips and he
saw hips.
>> She pleasth me well. It was peasant to
the eyes and a tree to be desired to
make one wise. We criticize people who
are not street wise.
You want to be street wise, pick a
street in the new Jerusalem.
Hallelujah to that.
>> Pick a straight in the new Jerusalem,
>> and be straight wise. She took of the
fruit thereof, and did eat, and gave
also unto her husband with her.
If you were determined to sin,
>> you're the preacher. If you're
determined to sin, come on, say what he
just said. Sin by yourself.
>> Do not be an agent to contribute to
someone's destruction. Sin by yourself,
>> not with your girlfriend.
I am very serious.
She gave to her husband
and he did eat.
Now she did not force her husband.
Were you here last night?
What was last night's message? The
danger
>> of good things. Putting good things
ahead of us. The Bible says, "He that
findeth a wife."
>> Mhm. Did Adam put a good thing ahead of
God? Yes.
and disaster followed.
So now I have no hair
because of Adam.
>> I'll get it back in the kingdom. Say
amen. Because of Adam, I look like this.
Yes, sir.
H Because of Adam, the hospitals.
What did God say to Adam? Because thou
hast hearkened unto the voice of thy
wife. When God said voice, what did he
mean?
the word she spoke.
We get back to the word.
You listen to someone else's word. Now,
there weren't three words. God's word,
the devil's word, and Eve's words. Eve's
words were
>> Satan's words.
And God is very direct because you
listened to someone else
who said something different from what I
said. Cursed is the ground for thy sake.
There are preachers who get into pulpits
and say the law is done away with.
That's somebody else's word, not God's
word. There are preachers who tell you
Christ nailed the law, the commandments
to the cross. That's somebody else's
word, not God's word.
>> There are preachers who tell you all you
have to do is love, not obey
commandments. That's somebody else's
word. Because God said, "If you love me,
what's our subject?"
>> By every word
this morning, what was our subject? Who
has your back? We talked about God and
God's power. Now, let me locate that
power for you.
It's in your hand.
The power to conquer sin, finish my
words,
>> is the word of God.
>> Whatever else you do, see a therapist, a
behavioral something, whatever else you
do, the foundation stone of any attempt
to change behavior must be the word of
God.
>> Now, let the word of God tell you why.
Let's go to Psalm 119. We read verse 9.
Psalm 119 verse 9. It's now 13 minutes
to five
>> to four. Sorry. Thanks for the
correction, sister.
>> Do you have Psalm 119?
We read verse 9. Are you there?
>> Let's read clearly and microscopically.
Read with me. Wherew with all shall a
young man cleanse his ways. Stop.
Now whether you're young or old, it
applies to you. But for some reason, the
psalmist targets a young man.
What do you understand by cleanse his
ways? He means take a shower.
>> What?
>> Get right with God.
>> Get rid of sin.
Conquer sin. How can a young man
conquer that secret habit that no one
sees?
And by the way, some old men.
Finish the verse.
By taking heed thereto according to thy
word.
Remember I told you the word that made
the universe is in your hand.
Which is a greater challenge? making the
universe or conquering a secret habit.
Making the universe.
If God has power to make the universe,
and that power is in his word, that same
power would enable God to change your
little world.
>> Wherewith all shall a young man or a
young woman or an old man or an old
woman change his ways, cleanse his ways.
How? By taking heed. Now all of us have
Bibles at home. How many of us take
heed?
We have some of us have several Bibles
at home. Give me one word for take heed.
>> Obey.
>> But to obey, you have to
>> to know what you're obeying. You have to
>> study.
>> Study. Did somebody say study?
>> You must study to know what? to obey
>> so we can properly say wherewith all
shall a young man cleanse his ways by
studying and obeying. Now listen to the
servant of the Lord Christ object
lessons page 100 paragraph 1. What did I
say?
Did you have lunch?
Christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
1. What did I say?
>> Very good. Listen carefully.
If studied and obeyed. Now what is the
word if introduced?
>> A choice and a
>> condition.
Condition. Without this condition
nothing will happen. If studied
and obeyed, the word of God works in the
heart,
subduing
every unholy attribute.
>> Name some unholy attributes. And don't
name them as though you like them. Just
name them.
>> Lying.
>> H,
>> cursing.
>> Pride.
>> What's that?
>> Oh, gossip.
Adultery.
>> Adultery.
>> Greed. H.
>> What did she say? Or he?
>> Cheating. Yes.
>> Cheating. What?
>> Gluttony.
>> Dishonoring your parents. And the list
is endless. Now listen again.
Identify the one that afflicts you. And
listen. If studied
and obeyed,
>> the word of God works in the heart,
not on the reproductive organs.
>> Nobody's listening.
>> Christ didn't die to change your
reproductive organs.
>> He died to change this. You know, this
we call it the heart. This when this
changes, everything changes. Why? out of
the abundance of the heart. Come on.
>> And the feet behave and the hands behave
and behaves.
It works in the heart. And so David
prayed, "What was David's great crime?
Adultery and murder." He did not say,
"Create in me a clean urinary tract.
Am I speaking the truth? Yes or no?
>> What did he say? Create in me a new
heart and renew right spirit within me.
Then everything else will change.
>> Because the urinary tract, the
reproductive organs are not
decision-making organisms.
>> Your appetite is not a decision-making
thing. your mind, the higher powers.
>> You're accustomed running around
punching people and you meet Jesus. He
doesn't change your fist. He changes
your mind,
>> your heart
>> out of the abundance. Now, this changes
this.
>> Listen to Ellen White again. The
ministry of healing, page 458, paragraph
1. Come on, tell me what I said.
Very good. You don't like to rebuke
twice. Okay. Very, very good. Here's
what the servant of the Lord says. The
whole Bible
is a revelation of the glory of God in
Christ. Listen carefully. Received,
believed, and obeyed.
It is the great instrumentality in the
transformation of character,
>> received,
believed and obeyed.
>> It is the great instrumentality. When
God wants to change you, he uses his
word.
>> Let's go to Psalm 119. Let's skip from
verse 9. That's where we were. Let's go
to verse 11.
You have that.
>> You can say that without looking. Thy
word have I hid where? In my heart. Mhm.
Why? That I might not sin against thee.
Now let's look at that.
Say the first part for me. Thy word have
I
>> where?
>> Now if the word is truly in the heart,
what has to go?
>> Sin. Because sin and truth cannot occupy
the same space.
>> Let us see that expressed differently.
Go to Malachi, the last book of the Old
Testament. Malachi chapter 2.
Let's read verse six. Malachi is
speaking for God and God is speaking to
the priests.
In other words, the preachers.
You have Malachi chapter 2.
Let's read verse six microscopically.
Let me pray again. Father, as we
continue,
speak through me clearly, Father. Give
me humility to listen to your spirit in
Jesus name. Amen. Malachi 2:6. Read
carefully now. The law of truth was
where?
>> Okay, stop.
The law of truth refers to the Ten
Commandments.
You don't believe me?
>> Go to Psalm 119. Don't lose Malachi 2.
Thanks for believing me, but let's
believe the word first. Go to Psalm 119.
Psalm 119. Read verse 142.
Psalm 119 verse 142.
Do you have that?
>> Some of you still looking desperately.
Do you have it now?
>> Read with me. Thy righteousness is an
everlasting righteousness, and thy law
is the truth.
>> Go to verse 172.
Verse 172 of Psalm 119. Do you have
that?
>> Read with me. What does that say? My
tongue shall speak of thy word, for all
thy commandments are
>> and righteousness is truth. Amen.
>> Now, let's go back to Malachi chapter
2:6
and we look at two statements.
Are you there?
>> Read the first statement. The law of
truth was in his mouth. Stop.
The law of truth, the law of God in his
mouth. Read the next statement. Iniquity
was not found in his lips.
Why?
>> Because the law of truth occupied it.
>> Some of you didn't get it.
>> Hold on.
Mr. cameraman,
let's assume this thing is full. Okay,
it's full.
to put something else in here. What
would I have to do? Yes.
Now this is truth.
This is my mouth.
To put iniquity in here, I have to do
what? Empty the truth to make room for
the iniquity.
>> The law of truth was in his mouth.
Because of that, iniquity was not. You
see, lips and mouth are the same thing.
This is just poetic writing.
>> Iniquity was not found where in his
mouth
>> because it was occupied with the law of
truth.
>> We're looking at how to conquer our
weaknesses.
Let's leave Psalm 119.
Let's go to John. John is my second
favorite book in the Bible. Beautiful
book written by the disciple closest to
Christ. He was also the youngest of the
12. He lived the longest and was the
only one who died a natural death. All
the others died violently for Jesus.
So you're expecting an easy life because
you have come to Christ. You're
forgetting there's someone called the
devil.
>> The closer you get to Christ, the more
angry Satan becomes.
>> When you accept Christ, you have
declared war on Satan.
>> That's right.
Okay.
>> What book did I say? John, what chapter
15? What? Verse three. Well, let's read
from one.
When you're there, say amen.
>> I am the true vine, and my father is the
husband man. Every branch in me that
beareth not fruit, he taketh away. And
every branch that beareth fruit, he
purgeth it, that it may bring forth more
fruit. Let me digress. Every branch that
beareth not fruit, he does what? Taketh
away. Now, who is he?
>> The God the Father, God the Son, God the
Holy Ghost. Who? Okay, let's think
again. Let's go to verse one. I am the
true vine. Keep reading. And my father
is the husband man. Now, let's identify
the work of the husband man. What does
he do? He prunes the vine. He takes care
of it. keep it healthy that it may grow
and produce. My father is the husband
man. Now verse two, every branch in me
that beareth not fruit, come on, he
taketh away. Who is he?
>> The father.
>> What does he do? He removes useless
branches.
>> If he removes them, they're going from
the branch or they going from the
church.
Are you not with me?
When you leave the church,
>> you're heading in the wrong direction.
>> God doesn't cleanse the church by
removing the church.
>> He cleanses the church by removing dead
branches.
>> So when you say the church is corrupt,
I'm leaving.
>> You're headed in the wrong direction.
That's the direction of removal.
>> This morning we read, was it this
morning? Yes. From John 8.
And when he was come down from the
mount,
great multitudes followed him. And
behold, they came a leper and worshiped
him, saying, Lord, if thou wilt, thou
canst make me whole or clean. Jesus put
forth his hand and touched him, saying,
I wilt be thou clean. And immediately
his leprosy was cleansed. And Jesus said
unto him, "See, thou tell no man, but go
thy way, show thyelves to the priest."
>> Now wait a minute.
>> Who healed him?
>> Who was Jesus?
>> God,
I'm trying to defend the church now.
>> God healed that man. But God still told
him, "Go and show yourselves to the
priest." Because the law of the Jews was
only a priest can declare a leper clean.
>> Jesus respected the church despite its
corruption.
>> Go. He said,
>> "Show
yourself and offer the sacrifice that
Moses commanded for a testimony unto
them." Moses said, "Give a s go and do
that even though I God cleansed you."
>> Yes, sir.
>> In Genesis 7, not Genesis, Luke 17, when
Jesus 10 lepers came to him, when he saw
them, Genesis, not Genesis, Luke 17:14,
he said unto them, "Go show yourselves
to the priests."
>> Which priest? The corrupt priests.
When you get up on your soap box and try
to tear down God's church, no, no, no,
no, no.
>> That is God's work, not yours.
>> It is a terrible thing to attack God's
church.
>> When the Israelites sinned, God sent
them into Babylonian captivity. When the
Babylonians were too too too eager in
their treatment, God sent Cyrus to get
rid of the Babylonians
and set his people free.
>> Do not put your hands on God's church.
>> Go show yourselves
to the priests. And so every branch in
me that beareth not fruit, he taketh
away. By the way,
if you've left the church because you
think the church is preaching errand,
you're preaching truth.
Elawite told a man who left this church
four times.
He was very brilliant, tremendous
preacher. I think it was Dudley Krite
and she told him, "If you're leaving,
go. But don't hang around God's people.
Don't come around God's church trying to
spread your error. If you're leaving,
leave.
Do not come around God's people. She
referred to the seventh day Adventist
church which was never perfect isn't
perfect now. But don't come around them
>> with your error.
>> Keep it to yourself.
>> Every branch in me that beareth not
fruit, he taketh away. And how does he
take it away? Go to John 6.
John 6. Ever heard of the straight
testimony?
H it shakes the church
I tell you John 6
Jesus was saying let's go to verse 51
of John 6 it's uh five after
somebody tell me four
I am the living bread which came down
from heaven if any man eat of this bread
he shall do what live forever and the
bread that I will give is my flesh which
I will give for the life of the world.
The Jews therefore strove among
themselves saying, "How can this man
give us his flesh to eat?" They could
not understand what Christ was saying.
What does verse 53 say?
Then Jesus said to them, "What?
>> Verily, verily, I say to you, except you
eat the flesh of the Son of Man and
drink his blood, ye have no life. None,
not some, none.
Who so eateth my flesh and drinkkeeth my
blood hath eternal life, and I will
raise him up when? At the last day. For
my flesh is meat indeed, and my blood is
drinkdeed. He that eateth my flesh and
drinkkeeth my blood dwellth in me, and I
in him. As the living father hath sent
me, verse 57, and I live by the father,
so he that eateth me, even he shall live
by me. And this is the word.
>> Amen.
The Jews kept hearing this, "Eat my
flesh." And the Jews didn't drink blood.
And so
in verse 60, many of the four disciples
when they heard this saying said, "What?
This is a hard saying.
>> Who can hear it?
>> This is too tough."
Verse 66 tells us what? From that time,
>> many of his disciples, come on, went
back and walked
out of the church
out
because the truth was too tough.
>> If you have a mind for truth, you will
never leave this church.
>> Now, I'm not saying the Adventist church
is perfect with respect to membership.
No. In John 6:7, Jesus said, "Have I not
chosen you 12? One of you
>> is a devil.
Jesus had 12 disciples. One 12th of the
church
>> was demonic.
>> And Jesus was still the pastor.
>> Let's say there's a church with 144
people. How many are demons? 12.
How's the membership of this church?
Don't tell me.
>> This is no joke.
>> There are demons in all churches.
in human form
>> always causing trouble
>> frustrating the gospel
>> in every church.
>> So when you say they're hypocrites in
the church is because it is God's
church. Why would the devil go to bar to
look for hypocrites?
>> Why would he go to a whole house?
>> They're already uh brother come up stand
next to me. They're already his.
What's the third favor I ask you? Think
>> the parable of the swer. What did Jesus
say about the wheat and the tears? Let
them grow to you.
>> At the end, I'll send the angels and
now let's go to John chapter 15:3.
How to conquer sin. Verse three of John
chapter 15.
Do you have it?
>> You read that verse for me. Now you're
clean. Come on. Through the word which I
have spoken unto you. Let's look at that
microscopically.
Now
this means before
they were not clean.
Why do you look at me like that?
Are you following me?
>> Oh, a good brother said we're uh
processing. Okay. Okay. Okay. How much
more time you need to process
>> now? Come on. Ye are clean. How? Through
the word that came from where? Which I
have spoke. Who said you shall surely
die? The same person.
Adam and Eve didn't follow it and they
became contaminated.
The word of God cleanses.
You clean through the word which I
here's Jesus Christ the mighty God. It
was he on si who said remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy. Let me say
it again. It was the voice of Jesus.
>> Because the moment Adam sinned, the
father no longer communicated directly.
That's why the Bible says there's one
mediator between God and man and men,
the man Christ Jesus. The instant Adam
sin, all communication came through
Christ.
>> It was he who came down to fix the
problem. It was he who spoke the law for
the father.
And he says you're clean to the word
which I have. But he also says every
word I speak I get from the father.
So when you listen to Jesus,
>> you listen to the father.
>> Now Jesus and the father and the holy
spirit who wrote the law by the way they
said the seventh day is the sun.
>> An emperor of Rome called Constantine he
said Sunday is a rest day.
Now we have the word of God and the word
of Constantine.
Eve had the word of God and the word of
Satan.
>> She chose the word of Satan. Today most
people choose the word of constant
which is really from Satan. I've told
you before, all truth comes from Satan
regardless of the agent through which it
comes. All all errors. Thank you. Oh,
God bless you. You're listening. Thank
you.
>> No, I'm serious. Thank you.
>> That's why you got to pray for the
preacher. You see what the devil's
right? You got to pray. Put your word.
All truth comes from
>> all error comes from Satan.
>> That's why I need to slow down. But you
didn't tell me to slow down. So, it's
your fault.
Ah, thanks. This is very serious.
We're talking about conquering sin.
If you Now listen again to this
quotation from Ellen White. The ministry
of healing page 458 paragraph 2. I gave
you earlier the ministry of healing 458
paragraph 1. Now it's 458 paragraph 2.
Just put comma two. Listen carefully.
The reason why the youth and even those
of mature years like me and some of you
are so easily led into temptation and
sin is because they do not study the
word of God and meditate upon it as they
should.
So Eli says both the young and the old
are easily led in now different sins but
sin is sin and the reason applies to
both. They do not study the word of God
and meditate.
Now listen carefully as we look at
meditate. Blessed is the man that
walketh not in the counsel of the
ungodly, nor standeth in the way of
sinners, nor siteth in the seat of the
scornful, but his delight is in the law
of the Lord, and in his law does he
meditate day and night.
>> Because you're under attack,
>> day.
When I was a little boy, I would I would
use a magnifying glass.
I'd locate the sun and then concentrate
the sun's beam on a piece of paper. What
would happen? The paper starts to burn.
Not immediately, but shortly thereafter.
Now,
we've got to concentrate God's word
on the cancer of sin.
>> Are you with me? Amen.
>> Make sure you got the son of
righteousness. Are you following me? We
concentrate that beam on that cancerous
cell, whatever it may be. We said greed,
cheating, lying, whatever.
And if we hold it steady, sir,
>> that beam will eventually cauterize.
>> But it can't be a flash.
Hold that beam.
>> Yes, sir.
Ellen White writes somewhere, I don't
recall where she said, "Ladies, don't
close your windows so the sunlight
doesn't shine on your couches." She
said, "Let the sun fade the couch."
That's what she says. But let the
sunlight cleanse the home of germs. Even
though it fades your couch now, does it
fade your couch instantly? No. It is
sustained exposure and eventually the
couch changes color. But she said, "Let
it happen. This word of God is light.
Yes, sir.
>> Ultraviolet light. When I travel, I take
with me a little thing to purify my
toothbrush. Now, the two most dirty
places in your house are your toilet and
your toothbrush.
Mhm.
Your toothbrush is one of the dirtiest
places in the universe. It really is.
And so, I put it in this little thing,
switch it on, and ultraviolet light.
They say, "Test your 99.9. It kills all
the germs of the toothbrush.
This is ultraviolet light from heaven.
>> And it's not restricted to 99.9.
It is all impurities. Are you with me?
Go with me now to Ephesians chapter 5.
It's 4:15. Ephesians 5. We read from
verse 25.
God is good
>> and all the time.
>> Yes. I like God very much.
God is a nice person.
He really is. You know, I recommend him
very highly.
>> God doesn't get the props he deserves.
Now, what book did I say? Ephesians,
what chapter 5, we read from verse 25.
When I read the first part of verse 25,
I hope all the sisters will say, "Amen."
Are you ready?
>> Husbands, love your wives.
Men say amen. Husbands love your wives.
>> A little weak. Even as Christ also loved
the church and gave himself for it. Read
with me now. That he might sanctify and
cleanse it. How? With the washing of
water. How? By the word.
>> Amen.
>> You cannot conquer sin outside of the
word of God. You don't conquer sin by
making a face.
>> It is not willpower that conquers sin.
It is the power of God
>> cooperating with your daily decision not
to offend God.
>> Remember the ministry of healing page
458 paragraph 1. Received, believed, and
obeyed.
>> It's a mistake to think decency prepares
you for heaven.
Now all children of God will be decent.
But all decent people are not children
of God.
Most atheists are decent.
There's some of us who think, "Okay, I
return a tie.
I drink distilled water.
I grew up an organic mother's milk.
I uh I walk 10,000 steps a day.
I uh I read diets and councils councils
of diets and foods.
I eat two meals, both of them very
small. And uh I'm ready for the kingdom.
The Bible says, "Let him that take that
think he standeth, come on, take heed,
let him."
A true child of God always feels
incomplete.
I'm not close enough.
>> I need to get closer.
>> I have a restless hunger that cannot be
satisfied for truth. And so I eat the
truth and I eat the truth and I eat the
truth. If I have to be obese, let me be
obese on truth.
>> Decency is fine, but decency doesn't
save you. You don't need God to be
decent.
>> You need God to be transformed. Can you
say amen? H you can change your behavior
without God. You cannot change your
heart without God.
>> Now that change is accomplished by the
word of God.
>> I cannot elevate. Go to Matthew chapter
8. Let me show you how important the
word of God is. Matthew 8,
we read verse 16. The word of God.
Matthew 8 verse 16.
I'm very impressed with the numbers who
stayed back this afternoon. God bless
you. I really mean that. God bless you
all of you.
And I said this morning, may God bless
you more than he blesses me. I wasn't
joking. The recording angel wrote what I
said. May God save you before he saves
me. Mhm. I really mean that. And I hope
your children enter the kingdom ahead of
you.
>> What book did I say? Matthew. What
chapter 8? What verse? Let me pray
again. Father, as I continue interacting
with your blessed, beautiful people,
keep me humble and speak through me in
Jesus name. Amen. Read with me
microscopically. Come on. And when the
evening was come, they brought unto him
many that were possessed with
>> and he cast out the spirits. How?
>> Now, now your second greatest enemy is
the devil.
What should you ask me?
Yeah,
he got ahead of you. Your greatest enemy
is yourself.
Here's how I usually express it. If the
devil dies right now,
we will sin tonight.
Nobody heard me.
If Satan dies of a heart attack right
now
>> and 5 minutes later all his demons
collapse, we will sin tonight
and tomorrow. We don't need the devil to
sin. Are you with me?
>> The word of God
is our defense against the enemy. Yes,
he's an enemy. He's a perpetrator. Not a
perpetrator. He's an instigator, but we
are the perpetrators.
>> What is it that diffuses Satan's hand
grenades? The word of God.
>> Amen.
>> You see
in Ecclesiastes 12:3, let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter. Fear God
and keep his commandments. Why? This is
the whole duty. That's all God wants.
Live by my ten commandments. This world
is a mind field.
You know what a mindfield is?
>> You can't see the mind.
You need a mind sweeper.
>> Yes, sir.
>> But if you have no mind sweeper, you
don't know where to step. You may lose
both legs.
God's law spots all the minds. And God
tells us, where is the camera? I want to
move a little bit. I don't like to move,
but I want to move a little bit. God
sees a mine right there. You don't see
it. And God says, "Thou shalt not
steal."
>> Yes, sir.
>> Step here.
You escape that mind.
>> Then he says, "Remember the Sabbath day.
Step here.
>> You escape that mind. Thou shalt not
commit adultery. Step here." With each
step, you're moving towards the kingdom.
Mhm. You're escaping the minds. Some of
us decide and we step on a mine and
boom. Then we say, "Where was God?" What
do you mean, where was God?
Right there.
The law of God is the highest expression
of his word.
I frequently say if you boiled the Bible
in a pot,
if you boil sea water after a while,
what do you have? Salt. If you boil the
Bible,
you come down with the Ten Commandments.
>> Question for you.
Did Satan sin
>> long before Adam and Eve were made? Did
sin? Yeah. How was it possible for him
to sin because there was a law?
>> First John 3:8, the devil sinned from
the beginning. There was a law. The law
is righteousness. Righteousness is God's
quality. It has always existed.
>> Are you with me?
>> The law of God, Jesus, here's one of the
reasons why Jesus came. Listen
carefully. There's therefore now no
condemnation to them which are in Christ
Jesus, who walk not after the flesh, but
after the spirit. For the law of the
spirit of life in Christ Jesus hath made
me free from the law of sin and death.
For what the law could not do in that it
was weak through the flesh, God sending
his own son in the likeness of sinful
flesh and for sin condemn sin in the
flesh. Listen now, that the
righteousness of the law might be
fulfilled in us. Amen.
>> What the law has
is what we cannot produce.
>> That's why we need Jesus.
>> You see, the law is not an instrument of
salvation. The law is a standard of
righteousness.
>> But the law is also power because God's
word is powerful. And the law is a part
of God's word. But different parts of
the word carry out different functions.
Also where the law exists as a living
reality,
sin as a lifestyle is impossible.
Impossible. And so the Bible says, "And
when the evening was come, they brought
unto him many that were possessed, not
bothered, possessed."
If you read the Bible carefully, no
possessed person can deliver himself.
>> A possessed person can't say, "I command
you to leave me."
Someone has to deliver you.
>> And the person effecting the deliverance
in the name of Jesus Christ must speak
on the authority of God's word or the
devil does not respect you.
There's a very funny story in Acts
chapter 19 of seven men. They were
professional exorcists. Don't ever set
out to be a professional exorcist. They
went to cast out a demon from a man. And
they said, "In the name of Jesus that
Paul talks about."
The demon said, "Now I know Paul
and I know Jesus." Well, who are you?
The Bible says one demon beat up seven
men. They ran out of the house bleeding
and naked.
>> The demons don't recognize you.
>> They're not afraid of you. They're
afraid of the word of God.
>> So in Matthew chapter 4 from verse one,
then was Jesus led up of the spirit into
the wilderness to be tempted of the
devil. And when he had fasted 40 days
and 40 nights, he was afterward and
hungered. And when the tempter came to
him, don't ever go to the tempter.
If there's a contact between you and the
Satan, let him come to you. Don't go to
him.
When Christ went to the wilderness, he
did not go looking for Satan. Because
we're told in Christ triumphant, page
190, paragraph 4, Christ had been
warned, do not enter into argument with
Satan.
When the tempter came to him, he said,
"If thou be the son of God, command that
these stones be made bread." But he
answered and said, "It is written."
Mhm. Man shall not live by bread alone,
but by every word that proceedth out of
the mouth of God.
>> If it is not from God's mouth,
>> no power.
>> Jesus relied on the word.
[Music]
If Christ relied on the word in his
battle with Satan, on what must I
relying?
>> I love good music. Say amen for good
music.
>> But here's the reality.
If a church advertises two events on the
same night in the same building in
different rooms, one event is a concert,
the other event is a Bible study, you
know which room will be empty.
>> Are you listening to me?
>> This people honorth me with their lips,
>> their hearts.
You want to overcome sin?
It is by the word of God.
>> The word that created, the word that
sustains, the word that casts out
demons.
When Jesus forgave people, he spoke it.
He said, "Thy sins be forgiven thee." It
is by the word that sins are forgiven.
It is by the word. 1 Thessalonians 4:16.
You know it so well. For the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout, with the voice of the archangel
and with the trump of God. Now, let's
pause and look at those three statements
with a shout. He will say something, not
just make a noise. God doesn't make
noises. He speaks
>> with a shout. With a voice of the
archangel and of the trump of God.
simply meaning he will speak loudly.
>> Yes, sir.
>> And the dead in Christ.
>> Now, wait a minute. Wait a minute. Let's
look at the power of the word.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Who's the first child of God to die?
>> Abel. So, if anyone is pure dirt, it's
Abel.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Are you with me?
>> This guy has been dead almost 6,000
years.
Jesus comes back
not touching the earth
from somewhere in the heavens. He stays
with the angels and he shouts
>> and Abel comes up.
>> Yes, sir.
>> You're not listening to me.
>> He does not. You see, he's not on the
earth taking dirt in his hands making
Abel again.
>> He speaks the word.
[Music]
Well, let's before we get to Abel,
the tomb of Lazarus.
>> John 11:43. And when he thus had spoken,
he cried with a loud voice. What did he
say? Lazarus, come forth. The Bible
says, "He that was dead came forth bound
hand and foot."
Lazarus was in the grave, his corpse.
Jesus was outside that cave.
The words of Jesus left his mouth
>> and produced life in a corpse.
>> It reversed death. Are you with me? The
words of God can reverse death.
>> Many of us, we are living corpses.
>> But the Bible says that 1 Timothy 5 6,
she that liveth in pleasure is dead
while she lives.
So tonight in some bar there'll be dead
people drinking
>> in some casino dead people gambling.
What can bring them to life? The word of
God.
>> That word will raise all the righteous
dead.
>> Yes sir.
>> That word that raised the son of the
widow of Na. That word that raised
Gyrus's daughter Damsel Aisha until they
arise. That word that will that raise
Lazarus,
>> that same word says in Ephesians 5:14,
"Awake thou that sleepest, and arise
from the dead."
>> Listen to me. It is this that gives life
to the spiritually dead.
>> It's like pulling teeth to get
Christians to study the Bible.
It's really sad, you know. It's really
unfortunate. And so, every species of
doctrine comes into the church and takes
people out.
>> So, we have Adventists denying the Holy
Spirit. We have Adventist preaching
Jesus is a created being.
We have Adventist preaching Ella White's
gift was not genuine.
all kinds of nonsense
because we do not study the word. Listen
to me. God has given you and me a
guarantee. Jesus expresses that in John
16:13. How be it when he, the Spirit of
truth, has come, he will guide you into
all truth.
>> Amen.
>> But I kept mentioning obey. There's not
a condition. In John 7:1 17, if any man
will do his will, a Uhhuh. he shall know
the doctrine, a willingness to obey,
>> he will know.
My brothers and sisters, you do not need
to be a slave to sin. The power to
conquer is the word of God. Amen.
>> The evening news will not give you power
to conquer sin. I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with the evening news,
but secular things provide no power over
sin.
>> As good as they are, the word of God
studied,
received,
obeyed,
>> that word that created heaven and earth,
that word that sustains heaven and earth
will recreate you.
and sustain you.
>> And so this evening in the name of Jesus
Christ and in the presence of the Holy
Spirit, I appeal to you, study this.
I gave you a quotation. The reason why
so many youth and even those of mature
years are so easily led into temptation
and sin is because they do not study the
word of God and meditate. Now to
meditate is to start thinking what is it
saying?
What's it saying to me? And you
literally think. Let me tell you
something. You do that for a few days,
your mind will start to change
>> because you're exposing your mind to the
sun of righteousness and sunlight kills
germs
>> and gives life.
>> Think
John 3:16, for God so loved the world
that he gave all. See, God didn't have
six or 10 begotten sons. He had one one
and gave him up
for the world or for you.
For you
that whosoever
believeth
should not perish but have everlasting
life. And you think you think as you
think you talk to God, Father, what are
you saying to me?
Mind, Character, and Personality. Volume
2, page 423, paragraph 2, Elawite
writes, "The gospel deals with
individuals."
How many of you will say, "Father,
by your grace and your power, help me to
set aside time every day for the study
of your word and meditation on that
word." Can I see your hand?
>> Do you mean that?
>> If you want your child's behavior to
change, study the word with your child.
>> And this word consistently studied will
transform us into the image of Christ.
>> Amen.
But we all with open face beholding as
in a glass the glory of the Lord are
changed into the same image from glory
to beholding. You look you look by study
by study you're looking at Jesus and it
changes you.
>> Don't look at your problems too too
much. Looking at them won't solve them.
The more you look at them the more you
become like them because by beholding we
become changed. So don't behold the
negative all the time. Behold the power.
If you're broke, don't behold your
bills.
>> Are you with me?
>> It won't cause them to disappear. You
behold the one who said, "The silver and
the gold is mine." You behold the one
who said, "The earth is the Lord's and
the fullness thereof." You behold the
one who said, "If ye bring the tithe
into the storehouse, I will bless you."
Amen.
>> Behold God.
Behold his word
and let the word do a miracle in your
life.
>> Now, before I get to the Q&A,
let me ask a few of you, what's your
favorite Bible passage?
Yes.
>> What does that say?
Why is that your favorite?
>> Mhm.
[Music]
>> All right. Okay. Somebody else. Your
favorite Bible verse.
>> Which says what?
>> Mhm.
By the way, we rest not against flesh
and blood, but against principalities,
powers. Remember that when you have a
dispute with someone in the church,
>> the devil is working through that person
>> to ruin your day.
>> Are you following me? But we can't see
the devil. We just see the person.
>> When Peter told Christ, "Don't go to
Jerusalem," Christ turned and rebuked
Satan. Because he realized Satan was
working through Peter. Satan may be
working through your children to send
you to a psychiatric institution.
>> Are you following me? You have to
recognize the work of the devil. He may
be working through your spouse
>> to cause you to age prematurely.
We wrestle not against flesh and blood.
Always remember there are two invisible
powers, God and the enemy. Somebody
else, what's your favorite verse?
Jude 24, which says what?
>> Mhm.
>> Now unto him that is able to what?
>> Mhm. Who is able?
>> You cannot keep yourself from falling.
Now you may avoid a particular sin. You
cannot avoid the power of sin.
You see,
a man with no legs and no arms who's
bedridden, can he sin? Yes. Cuz sir is
here first.
Somebody else, your favorite verse. Yes.
>> Joshua.
>> Joshua 19 says, "What?
>> Just pause right there. It's not a
suggestion.
>> Have not I commanded you?" Go on.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yes. The Lord
>> is with you.
>> Don't be afraid is a command.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Second Timothy 1:7. God hath not given
us the spirit of fear, but of power and
of love and of a sound mind. You are
commanded, "Do not be afraid."
>> But God gave that command to his people.
>> If you're not God's child, please be
afraid.
>> Are you threatening to raise your hand?
Yes.
Say it again.
>> And what does that say?
>> Yes. Yes. Through Christ. Without me, he
can do nothing.
>> Yes, sister.
Jeremiah. What?
Uh-huh.
Blessed is the man that trust in God and
his
>> God. Yes. Trust in God. Remember this
morning, put not your trust in man.
Trust in God
>> through the word. Not through what you
see. Through the word.
>> Yes, sister.
Yes.
Of the Almighty.
[Music]
>> Yes.
Mhm.
[Music]
>> Mhm.
Yes. Okay. Okay. That was my mother's
favorite psalm by the way. Psalm 91.
Beautiful psalm. Come to my brother than
you.
>> Which says what?
>> Now notice what the verse says. Thou
will keep him. You cannot keep yourself
in peace.
>> Because peace is a gift of God.
>> Notice what Jesus says. Peace I give to
you. My peace. Peace I leave with you.
My peace give I unto you, not as the
world giveth. The peace of the world is
not peace.
It is a suspension of hostilities. It is
not peace. The peace God gives allows
you to sleep through a storm on the
lake. Are you following me? That's the
peace of God. The peace of God allows
you to tell Nebuchadnezzar, "We're not
we're not hesitant to talk to you. We're
willing to burn, but we're not bowing.
That's peace."
>> Yes, sir.
>> Yes.
Yes.
>> Yes. God thinks no evil thoughts about
people. We have the same thing. First uh
Corinthians 13:5. He thinkketh no evil.
Somebody else. Yes.
In all thy ways.
Now in all thy ways acknowledge him.
What does that mean?
>> You're thinking of getting into a
romantic relationship, acknowledge him.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Are you following me? Yes, sir.
>> You want to enroll in a university,
acknowledge him. Find one that does not
have Sabbath exams. Don't get into it
and then tell the church, "Pray for me."
>> Think of God first.
>> Avoid situations that challenge your
faith.
>> In all thy ways, acknowledge him. Apply
that when you're about to buy a dress
or shoes.
Am I speaking error?
>> Am I speaking truth?
>> In all thy ways. You apply that when
you're pushing your cart down the meat
section.
>> Okay. You don't like me. Okay. All
right. Yes. Dr. Marcado. Yes.
Romans what?
>> Yes.
By the re Yes.
What is good, acceptable?
Yes. The mind must be renewed. And
what's the power that renews it? The
word of God. Somebody else. Yes.
>> Revelation. What?
It says what?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Thank you. That the foundation of
our worship to God is the fact that he
is creator.
>> You see, before there was sin, there was
worship.
And the worship wasn't based on Calvary.
There was no Calvary. The worship was
based on the fact that God is creator.
In the new world, worship will be based
on the fact that he is creator. Now, our
primary purpose for worship is still the
fact that he is creator because
salvation is spiritual creation.
>> That's why the Sabbath is so central in
the gospel. It elevates the savior who
is creator. Remember, the one who did
all of this can do it spiritually in
your lives. Yes, sister.
Uh-huh.
Mhm.
Yes.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
All right, sister. Ye have not chosen
me, but I you do you know you cannot
choose God first. God has to choose you.
>> Let me show you quickly, then we get to
the Q&A. I'll come to you. Go to Romans
chapter 3 quickly. You have five seconds
to find it. You have four seconds.
Three. Two. You're all flunked. Okay.
Romans chapter 3. Let's read from verse
10. Do you have that?
>> You're still looking. All right. Romans.
Help your neighbor to find it before the
sun sets. Okay. Do you have it now? Read
with me. As it is written. Come on.
There's none good know not want.
Carefully now. There's none that
understand if carefully now. There is
none that seeketh after God. Stop.
Listen to me carefully. You cannot seek
God.
God has to seek you.
>> Do you think because you came to church
you were seeking God?
>> The carnal nature does not seek God. It
does not seek life as God defines life.
It does not seek righteousness. It seeks
self.
>> There is none that seeketh after God.
That's why Jesus told uh Zakius in Luke
19:10, "The son of man is come to seek
and to save that which is lost."
Have you heard of seeker friendly
churches?
You set up your service to please
seekers.
No one seeks God.
You need churches that please God, not
seekers.
[Music]
>> I can tell when you've tuned me out.
Okay.
Uh,
yes.
I can't hear you.
>> Isaiah what?
Yes.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Mhm.
>> Yes.
Help thee.
>> Yes. And in the Bible, the right hand is
a side of power. Where does Jesus sit?
On the right hand of God. Where was the
angel standing when he appeared to
Zacharias in the temple to tell him he
have a son? On the right hand. Where did
Jesus tell the disciples, cast your net
on the right side of the boat? The right
side is the side of power. It's not that
the left side of God is weak, but the
right side is used to express power.
>> The right hand of God doeth valiantly.
All right, somebody else.
Uh, who? Yes, sister. Oh, brother
Neville, it's your turn. No. Okay.
>> Yes.
Wheel,
whether or not
>> Amen. And the willingness to obey is
essential to understanding God's word.
Yes, sister.
>> Psalm 119. Yes. 105.
>> Yes.
>> Thy word is the lamp unto my feet, a
light unto my
>> path. Amen. It tells you how to go.
>> Remove the word, you're walking in
darkness.
>> Mhm.
Yes.
>> Yes.
>> Uhhuh.
>> If we follow this principle, we live
blessed lives.
>> Not problem- free lives, blessed life.
Seek ye first the kingdom of God and his
righteousness.
>> Where?
>> Revelation 21.
>> Who speaking? Oops.
>> Oh yes. Go ahead.
>> Revelation 21:4.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And God shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes. And there shall be no more
pain neither
there'll be any more pain
>> for the former things are passed
>> and that day is coming.
>> And we need to spend time thinking of
the coming of Christ. Do not be so
absorbed in day-to-day living we forget
Jesus Christ is coming back.
as literally as tomorrow is coming.
>> Let me say it again.
>> Jesus Christ is coming back
>> to deliver his and destroy his enemies.
>> Isaiah, oh, sorry, Isaiah 41:10 where it
says, "Fear thou not, for I am with
thee.
>> Be not dismayed, for I am thy God. Yes,
>> I will strengthen thee.
>> Yay, I will help thee.
>> Yay, I will uphold thee with the right
hand of my righteous.
>> Yes, I will strengthen you, says God.
And for those of us who feel weak, the
power by which God strengthens us is
his. You cannot get around the word of
God. Yes.
>> John 3:16.
>> Mhm. For God so loved the world that he
gave his only begotten son.
>> Yes.
>> That whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have everlasting life.
>> All right. Everlasting life lasts how
long? Forever. No death, no sickness, no
pain, no sin. Yes.
through the power of the Holy Ghost.
That's Romans 15:13.
>> Amen. Sister, you said that with joy.
God bless you. God bless you. Okay.
Where are we now?
>> Where? Oh, yes.
>> No, we just
>> Oh, where are we?
>> Yeah.
>> Who is it?
>> Oh, you are. Okay. Go ahead.
[Music]
>> Okay. We're giving you a microphone and
I can't hear anything.
Matthew 25-27
Therefore I say unto you, take no
thought for your life, what ye shall
eat, or what ye shall drink.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Nor yet for your body what ye shall put
on. Is the is not the life more than
meat, and the body more than
>> raignment.
>> Behold the fowls of the air.
>> For they sow not,
>> neither do they reap,
>> nor gather they into barns. Mhm.
>> Yet your heavenly father feedth them.
Are ye not be much better than they?
>> Mhm.
>> Which of you by taking thought can add
one cubit unto his stature?
>> Where are you reading from? Matthew
what?
>> Matthew 25-27.
>> What chapter?
>> Oh, chapter six.
>> Okay. God bless you. Yes. That teaches
us to depend on God. God says, "If I
feed the birds, if I clothe the grass,
if I close the liies, I'll take care of
you." Because I didn't die for liies and
grass. I died for you. If I take care of
those, I'll take care of you.
>> Yes. Who's next? Yes, sister.
>> Isaiah 40:31. But they that wait upon
the Lord shall renew their strength.
They shall mount up with wings like
evils. They shall run and not be weary.
They shall walk and not faint.
>> Amen. Amen. Yes.
>> Oh, okay. Where are we now? Right here.
Right here.
>> Oh, okay. I'll get to it. Yes. Go ahead,
sister.
>> 2 Samuel 2, I'm sorry. 2 Samuel
14:E14.
>> Uhhuh.
>> For we must needs die and are as water
spilled on the ground, which cannot be
gathered up again. Neither do God
respect any person. Yet does he devise
means that his banish be not expelled
from him.
>> All right. Thank you very much. Okay.
Someone in authority told me we need to
get to the Q&A.
A member of the Has Sanhedrin told me
that. So, I have to obey.
I must obey. Before we get into that,
let me Oh, no. I must get my little
friend right here. I must get my little
friend right here.
>> Mhm.
>> Jesus loves me and everyone.
Amen.
>> All right. Amen.
All right. A little child shall lead
them. Yes. Okay. Let's pray for wisdom
before we get into the Q&A. Father in
heaven, thank you for your people who
love your word. If we've offended you,
forgive us, please. Now, dear God, grant
me your spirit as I try to under answer
these questions. Help us to ask
questions with the right motive because
every action is judged by the motive.
Questions that will allow everyone to
benefit and not just stir up hostility
and controversy. In the name of Jesus
Christ, I pray. Amen.
>> All right, some nice easy Bible
questions
and the emphasis is Bible and easy.
>> Who has the first question?
>> We have the mic. All right.
Now, keep in mind, short questions are
more likely to get accurate answers.
Long questions make it much more likely
you get convoluted responses. So, keep
the questions as short as possible and
don't preach. All right, two short
questions. Question one,
two short questions. One, when you open
your Bible as you go up to preach, is
there a certain text that it opens to or
is it
>> No, I just this symbolizes my dependence
on the word of God.
>> Okay,
>> I'll tell you why quickly. I was in
Australia preaching and I started
preaching with a Bible closed and God
blocked out my memory.
>> And he told me, don't ever do that.
>> Okay?
>> And he punished me. And from that time
until then, I have never closed the
Bible.
>> Amen. I depend on this.
>> Amen. Second question. Yes.
>> Um
with GC session, what has been the most
encouraging thing that you have noticed
from this year's session?
>> A smooth transition of power at the very
top.
>> From Elder Wilson to Elder Moher, is
that his name?
>> Coler. Yes. Smooth transition. And I
also saw two divi a division president
embracing the new president. I like the
smooth transitions. I was touched by
that. Mhm. Thank you. God bless you.
Now, I won't decide who gets to ask the
questions in what order. I'll let my
bosses do that. So, you will tell me
who's asking questions. All right. Yes,
my brother.
I wanted to know
why God hasn't created
>> Eve in the first place.
Why God created Eve
>> hasn't created Eve in the first place?
>> I didn't get the question.
>> Why God hasn't created Eve in the first
place?
>> Why did God create Eve in the first
>> What I mean by that,
>> hold on, hold on. Let me clarify.
>> Oh, why didn't he create Eve first?
>> In the first place. That means what I
means by that. Uh-huh.
>> He created Adam first and after
probably upon request Adam's request,
he created Eve.
Why at the same time? Why didn't they at
the same time?
>> Let me see if I get the question.
Why did God create man and woman in the
order in which he did? Yes.
>> You can say that way.
>> Yes. Mhm.
>> Well,
go to 1 Timothy chapter 2. Let's get a
clue. 1 Timothy chapter 2.
Part of that verse will be
controversial, but we'll get beyond it
and go to the part that I want.
Do you have 1 Timothy chapter 2? Let's
read from verse 11.
Are you there?
>> Yes. Did I pray and ask God for wisdom?
>> I didn't pray. Oh,
>> I did. Another prayer won't help. Let's
pray. Father, supervise this session. I
pray. Speak through me in the name of
Jesus Christ. Amen. Read verse 11. But I
soften out a woman to
do. You have 2 Timothy 2:1.
>> What does that say?
Let a woman woman sell us with all
subjuggeste, but I suffer not a woman to
teach, not to user authority over the
man. Now read verse 13.
>> For Adam was first formed, come on, then
Eve. In other words, one of the reasons
God used that order was to establish the
man as the head of the family and the
head of the Eden home.
That's why one reason God chose that
order. It was not random. He made him
first because he was first in
responsibility. So when God told Adam,
you shall not eat of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil. Eve had not
been made. It was Adam's duty now to
tell his wife what God had said. So it
symbolized represented the role as head
bought. I don't know why it says in a
few places Adam was crowned king of
Eden. She never writes Eve was crowned
queen of Eden. Adam was crowned king.
not dictator, not boss, but the one with
primary responsibility. So that the
Bible says, "Wherefore, as by one man
sin entered in the world, not by woman,
by one man." So Adam was first to show
that God had chosen him as the head of
the home and the head of the church.
Um
I'm not completely surprised
because
>> he was complaining and when he saw all
the animals uh in pairs
>> Mhm.
>> and uh oh what happened? Why I am by
myself?
>> Now
when Adam saw the animals he didn't see
anyone to match him. But that wasn't
that doesn't mean God didn't know what
he was going. God always knows what he
will do. Are you with me? So God didn't
change his mind after Adam examined the
animals. It was always God's plan to
make a woman. But Adam had to see he had
a need for this woman. Now to show
that's the way God functions in John
chapter 6 where Jesus Christ fed the
6,000. He said in verse 5, "When shall
we buy bread that these may eat?" He
told Philillip. And this he said to
prove him. Verse six, for he himself
knew what he would do. God always knows
what he will do and why he is doing. And
so Adam who being created being finite
not knowing anything he had to be shown
you need a companion someone who matches
you. And then God made Eve but it was
always God's intention to make them in
that order. It wasn't a parade of
animals that put the idea in God's head
to make Eve.
>> Amen. All right. Okay.
>> I'm I'm glad the brother raised that we
serve a God who has everything under
control.
>> Are you with me?
>> The world may look may look chaotic, but
God is orchestrating everything
>> for his eventual glory. All right. Who's
next?
>> Oh, yes, Dr. Neville.
>> Uh, I have a theory about this verse,
and I'm hoping that your answer might
confirm my theory.
This verse is found in uh Hebrews uh
5:9. It says, "And having been
perfected," speaking of Jesus,
>> "He became the author of eternal
salvation to all who obey him." My
question is,
>> how is perfection perfected? How is
perfection perfected? All right, that's
that's an interesting verse. Now, Jesus
Christ, like any other human being, had
to develop a character.
And he developed that through obedience
to the father. Jesus Christ. Let me put
it this way. Before Christ came to this
earth,
>> he was God. Right or wrong?
>> Right?
>> Was he righteous?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. But the righteousness that's
applied to us is not the righteousness
Christ had before he became human.
>> Is the righteousness he worked out in
his life by perfect obedience to the
law.
>> You see, God as God does not have to
obey law.
Let me say it again. God does not have
to obedience to the law is an act of
worship.
>> Who will God worship?
>> God is above law.
>> So the righteousness of God that Jesus
had as God is not what is given to us.
Now this same righteousness was worked
out in his humanity through obedience to
the father. And so the righteousness of
Christ is his perfect obedience which is
attributed to us or imputed to us when
we put our faith in him. The
righteousness perfect obedience to the
law of God. But in his full divinity
before he became human Christ didn't
obey law. He's God. He's above all law.
And so Christ had to grow. Uh Luke 2:52.
And Jesus increased in wisdom and
stature and in favor with God and man.
And so he grew, he grew, he grew. So
yes, he developed fully. And development
is a form of perfection. You see, a
human being grows in perfection. God's
perfection does not have to grow because
God doesn't change. God can't get
better. But a human being grows. And so
Jesus grew in the spirit and in grace
and developed. Yes. That's as far as I
can go.
>> Thank you. Oh, you're welcome, my good
brother. God bless you.
>> Definitely. Uh yeah, you you confirmed
what I was thinking.
>> All right. Okay. Sure. All right. Thank
you. And may God continue to bless your
voice.
>> Yes, sister.
>> Yes. This is a question about you. You
know the whole Bible. Have you
memorized?
>> That's not a Bible question about me.
No, I haven't. I just have two or three
verses. But I keep working on it every
day. Not just to preach, just as a
lifestyle. Every day I'm memorizing and
reciting. I mean, every single day when
I go to the gym,
>> do you spin in?
>> Well, I don't I don't count. It's always
on my head. If I go to the gym to
exercise, if I do a bench press, I do a
set of 10 reps while I'm resting, I
recite chapters.
>> Wow.
>> So, I choose the chapters I'll say in
the gym. I don't just sit in the bench
and recover and do that's a waste of
time. So I use that to maybe Revelation
15, just eight little verses, you know,
Psalm whatever 103 with 22 verses, short
passages, but all the time. All the
time. If I'm driving, I leave the gym, I
recite until I get home.
>> Wow.
>> When I leave home to go to the gym, I
recite until I get to the gym.
>> Wow.
>> When I'm showering, I recite.
>> When I'm brushing my teeth, I recite.
Don't ask me any more questions. I just
recite. I recite. Thank you, sir.
>> So, my sister, it's constant work, but I
love to do it.
>> Amen.
>> You can do the same thing.
>> Mhm. God bless you. Yes, my dear sister.
>> Oh, my mistake. I have sinned. Okay.
>> Yes, my brother.
>> Um, I know you said uh no controversy,
but I may have a question that's
slightly controversial.
>> Well, I'll I'll let you know if it's
controversial or not. Go ahead. So there
are many Christians who are turning away
from the Bible because they say that the
66 books as we know them is not the
complete Bible.
>> What are your thoughts on uh these
so-called missing books, specifically
the book of Enoch?
>> Mhm. Okay. In the Catholic Bible, we
have something called the uh duterro
canonical books. Deuteronom means
second. So the Catholics have a second
cannon and they're added to the 66 and
they're called the the um the the
Apocrypha. Now those books can be read
for a few historical details that they
contain but they're not considered
canonical books in the Christian world.
Are you with me? There are a lot of
other there's there's the apocrypha.
There's the pseudoigrapher. There a lot
of other books that are written that
carry the names of famous spiritual
people not written the gospel of Thomas.
Other books Daniel and the bell the
dragon all kinds of books but they were
not
chosen by the church. You see canon
canonicity which is a fancy word for
eligibility for being included in the
canon or qualify qualification for being
regarded the book of God had to have a
couple of things. One, the book had to
be have an aspostolic author. Was the
author someone who walked with Jesus or
who walked with someone who walked with
Jesus?
>> You look at the books of the Bible from
Matthew. Now, the argument is never over
the Old Testament. Really, it's usually
the new. So, from Matthew to Revelation,
Matthew walked with Jesus. Mark didn't,
but Mark hung out with Peter. Luke
didn't walk with Jesus, but Luke hung
out with Paul. John walked with Jesus.
Then Luke wrote the book of Acts. Then
we have Paul, write, you know, Paul was
directly taught by Jesus Christ. So he
wrote one quarter of the New Testament.
James was a brother of Jesus Christ.
Peter walked with Christ. Jude was a
brother of Jesus Christ. Hebrews, we
believe, was written by Paul. And so
they all have apostolic authority.
>> Amen.
>> Those other books do not have that
authority. I'm not a manuscript expert,
but they don't have that apostolic
authority and they have doctrinal errors
that conflict with the books of the
Bible
>> doctrinal. And now the Mcabes, for
instance, they have valuable historical
information. They bought four books of
the Mcabes, very valuable historical
information, but they're not canonical
in the sense that they're not included
among the 66 divinely inspired books.
But if you read them, read them
carefully. Don't read them looking for
doctrinal information. You may read them
out of carefully guided curiosity. But
if remember curiosity can get you into
trouble.
>> Yes sir.
>> So I don't tell people don't read them.
That only increases the curiosity. But
ask God keep me from error.
>> Next question.
>> Hello. Um
>> hi.
>> Uh my name is Carllet Mackenzie.
>> Your name is what?
>> Carlet McKenzie.
>> Carlet. Carlet
>> Carlet.
>> Okay. Sister Colette McKenzie, how are
you?
>> I'm good.
>> Good.
>> I am 28 years old. I'm on the young. I'm
28 years old.
>> So I am the youngest of the millennials,
you you would say.
>> And so my question
>> uh
>> is a little bit Bible related, but
essentially over the last few months
I've seen a concerning rise of like AI
and all of these types of things. I have
to necessarily go in on exactly what it
is and whatnot, but there's a concerning
rise and the world as we know it is
about to radically change. They're
saying by like 2027. And I've been
studying the book of Revelation and
such. So, I'm just curious on um if you
see AI and Revelation or like how do you
think this rise of AI because it's
coming whether we realize it or not.
There's this massive a Yes. And it's
only getting smarter. AGI. Once it hits
AGI, we're pretty much as humans. But
>> now, I can't say I've seen AI in
Revelation. I've seen deception in
Revelation. And AI would just be one way
to deceive people. The devil finds
multiple ways to deceive. But if we boil
it down to essentials, deception is
anything that varies from thus sayith
the Lord. Therefore, your defense
against AI or any other modern
technology is to know what the Bible
says and to stick to it regardless of
social movements. So, yes, there are
means to deceive people that are
powerful. Someone sent me a clip. Did I
tell you last night of uh me speaking
words I never spoke?
>> And it was me. As far as my eyes could
see, it was me.
>> Very scary.
>> Very scary. But when your foot is
planted on thus said the Lord, you
cannot be deceived.
>> All right, sister. God bless you, Sister
McKenzie.
>> Okay.
>> Is it on? Okay.
>> How are you?
>> I'm good.
>> Good.
>> Um, you'll answer this quickly.
>> Okay. Um, whenever I read the texts
about, you said it this morning when you
were preaching and you said the the the
demons were inside of him and what is
your name and legion and you said, you
know, they said, "Don't hurt us."
>> When he put the the demons and the evil
spirits into the pigs
>> and the pigs went crazy
>> and went down. Okay.
>> Okay. The pigs drowned.
>> Yes. What happened to the evil spirits?
>> Nothing.
>> Nothing. Nothing. Evil spirits will be
destroyed when Jesus comes.
>> Okay. Yes. Okay. Yes. Yes.
>> So, so they went where?
>> Well, they probably just left the pigs.
Mhm. But they didn't drown.
>> They didn't drown. I
>> No. No. As far as we know, no.
>> But were they there to go into other
people?
>> Well, of course.
>> Oh,
>> of course. Demons were destroyed when
Jesus comes the third time.
>> That's after the millennium.
>> Why did they ask to be put in the pigs?
Because the devil is destructive.
>> Satan is he is a destroyer and his
demons are just the way he is destroys.
They destroy. So they got into the pigs
>> made. By the way, demons don't only
possess adults. They possess animals and
they possess children. Okay,
>> it's a little digression, but I should
tell you parents, demons can possess
children,
animals, and adults.
>> Okay.
>> The devil is an equal opportunity
employer when it comes to that.
>> Mhm. So, there's no evidence the demons
were destroyed. No.
>> Gotcha. Okay.
>> Because remember, the demon said, "Don't
torment me."
>> Yes.
>> You see, don't hurt me.
>> But Jesus said, "Go to the pigs." Go to
the pigs. Mhm. All right.
>> All right. Thanks.
>> You're welcome, my dear sister.
Okay, Pastor Ski, I'm Nicole.
>> Who's Nicole? Oh, hi Nicole.
>> Hi. So, my question is um going in the
order of what the Bible referenced with
Adam and Eve and then the children.
>> And then in
chapter 4 verse 17, it says Cain knew
his wife. And I remember one time my
father
>> in chapter in chapter 17. No, no. Cain
in Genesis chapter 4 17 and Cain knew
his wife.
>> And I remember one time my father,
>> he asked me this question. He says,
"Well, where where did those people come
from?"
>> Um, after
the original people
>> So, so who are those people?
>> Who did Ken marry?
>> Yeah.
>> Let's go to Genesis chapter 5.
>> Yeah. So, um, okay. So, is that out of
maybe sequence?
>> Out of what? out the sequence being that
it gives the history.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. It's okay.
>> I started thinking I was like, well,
maybe
>> the Bible isn't always chronological.
>> Okay.
>> It is thematic, not always
chronological. Yes.
>> So, when Cain married a wife in 4:17, we
learn in chapter 5 that Adam had sons
and daughters. Clearly, Cain married a
daughter. That practice still goes on
today.
>> Hundreds of years later, Abraham married
his halfsister.
>> Right. Siri. Yes. So, it's out of
sequence.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. God bless you.
>> Yes, sister.
>> Hello, Pastor.
>> Hello, sister. God bless you.
>> Uh just to give you
uh some context about four years ago, I
started to listen to your sermons.
>> Okay. And I wanted to ask you
if a woman could divorce her husband
because that was something that I was
>> If a woman could divorce her husband.
>> Yes.
>> Because that was something that I was um
faced with.
>> Um it's been about three years since I'm
now divorced.
>> But she must have biblical grounds.
>> Yes.
>> I'm not asking for your grounds. I'm
simply saying she must have bib and the
the single clear biblical ground is
adultery.
>> Adultery.
>> And Ellawite is clear. The Bible has one
reason for divorce.
>> Now the church offers a few more but the
Bible elawite is clear. Scriptures offer
one clear basis for divorce. That is
adultery.
>> Adultery. Mhm.
>> And the Bible says if you so look at a
woman and lust after her in
>> your heart if you
>> if you look after a woman after a woman
>> you have already committed adultery.
>> Yes.
>> And so a woman being married to a
husband knows his practices.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And so
I decided to divorce.
>> But yet you can't divorce a man for
lusting.
>> No. No. I'm I'm not um saying that I can
judge his heart,
>> but being married,
>> I had evidence
>> or that he committed adultery.
>> Adultery.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Now, even though you
have evidence, you didn't have to
divorce because God loves
reconciliation.
>> Yeah.
>> So, even though divorce is allowed for a
particular reason, you don't have to
divorce because the Bible tells us in
Genesis chapter 3 that God drove out the
man. The word there also means divorce,
but Christ came to bring him back. So
God in Malachi 2:16, the Lord, the God
of Israel, saith that he hateth putting
away. Calvary is evidence. God prefers
reconciliation. Sometimes that is not
possible.
>> But there is biblical grounds for
divorce. It is chiefly adultery. If you
had that evidence, okay.
>> And if they're not willing to reconcile,
>> Yes. Right. Right. You can't force the
other person to reconcile. No, you
can't. So now my question is
>> Oh, that wasn't the question. Okay.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> That was the context.
>> Oh, that was the context. No more
context, please. Okay. Go ahead.
>> So, it says in 1 Corinthians 7:39. It
says, "The wife is bound by the law as
long as her husband liveth, but if her
husband be dead, she is at liberty to be
married to whom she will. Only in the
Lord." Mhm.
>> Would that apply to a divorced woman?
>> If the if the if the husband be dead,
she's what?
>> It says a wife is bound by the law as
long as her husband liveth. And so if
the Lord says he hateth putting away,
>> it says that whatever God has put
together, let no man put us under.
>> So earthly divorce isn't the same.
>> God, the Bible allows you to divorce.
>> Mhm. You see now divorce is not God's
ideal will.
>> Yes,
>> divorce is allowed because of the
hardness of your heart. So divorce is
the product of sin. God allows it but he
doesn't like it.
>> Meat eating is the product of sin. God
allows it but he doesn't like it. So
there are things God allows but they're
not ideal.
>> Mhm.
>> Are you with me?
>> Yes.
>> You can go to college, get a D, and
pass. That's not ideal. You want an A.
Are you with me? So divorce is allowed
but not ideal. So even though God
doesn't like it, he allows it.
>> So then is the wife bound by law as a
law.
>> If you are biblically divorced and
Ellite is clear, you are free to
remarry.
>> So you use biblically divorce. Is that
>> adultery? Adultery. So if you're
>> if you say you have evidence this nice
man committed adultery,
>> he does not care about reconciliation,
you are free to remarry. Don't
complicate it. You are free to remarry.
>> But if it says the wife is bound by the
law as long as her husband liveth, how
is that?
>> Now, now that's that's a a verse that is
controversial.
>> It's controversial verse. We need clear
verses to make personal decisions. One
clear verse is is that for adultery
Matthew chapters 5:28 29-30 you divorce
is based on adultery you can divorce if
you have evidence or proof of adultery
and our servant messenger of the Lord
tells us the innocent party can remarry.
>> It says that in God's word.
>> Say that again.
>> The innocent party can Well, not as
clear as Elite puts it in the word. No,
not as clear. But she says you can
remarry.
>> But that's Ellen White. Where does it
say that God says a divorced woman can
get remarried?
>> Mhm. Well, there's not a verse that says
that as explicitly as that. No,
>> but our scholars have studied this.
>> So then I'll be more specific.
>> Yes.
>> If a woman is divorced, so I told you
that I'm divorced.
>> Yes.
Does God not consider me my first
spouse's wife?
>> No.
>> So, I'm not a wife.
>> In God's eyes?
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Because he's given you permission to
divorce. No.
>> Okay.
>> That's a biblical divorce.
>> It's not ideal, but it's allowed.
So, don't make it more difficult than it
is. No.
>> Mm-
>> All right.
Now, if you want to live the rest of
your life single, that's fine.
But no, if you have reasons for divorce
and the church grants it, and Lloyd
makes it very clear, you are free to
remarry if you so desire.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> You're using,
>> but be careful how you choose the second
time.
>> All right.
>> Hello, pastor.
>> Hi.
>> I want uh again, it's uh Joffrey. I just
wanted to thank you for praying for me
last night as well. Yes, my brother.
>> Very well today.
>> Okay. Oh, God bless you.
>> Um,
>> I felt moved today during my sermon to
preach Hebrews 4.
>> Mhm.
>> Or at least part of it.
>> Um, part of the sermon.
>> I was wondering what your thoughts were
on this. um here in Medson when after
the great disappointment it was in the
field
>> and God touched him with the book of
Hebrews
>> which solved the advent problem
>> showing where Christ was going into the
most holy.
>> Right.
>> Hebrews is such a pivotal book and the
advent movement
>> for these last days. And it struck me
why does no one ever teach Hebrews 4 or
quote it ever? It completely vindicates
the seventh day creation Sabbath.
>> It establishes that God made it a
certain specific day
>> and and it completely condemned Sunday
worship by saying if Jesus had another
day, would he not have spoken of it? It
completely destroys the Sunday argument.
>> And I just wonder why what your thoughts
were. Why no Adventist ever preaches it?
>> It's so clear in New Testament.
>> Well, I wouldn't say no one ever you
perhaps you have not heard. Yeah. Right.
Yeah, but we don't know what people
preach all over the world. You see, but
also keep in mind there are four
gospels. Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
>> John says nothing about the birth of
Jesus.
>> Nothing about the childhood of Jesus.
Matthew mentioned it. Luke me John's 92%
of John is not found in Matthew, Mark
and Luke. So different people stress
different things. Elite said one
preacher stresses one thing, another
preacher is not attractive to another
teaching. But when they both speak, more
light comes to God's people. And so
different people stress different
things. But I'm sure there people who do
appreciate, but we just have not yet
heard them.
>> And now God may use you to be one of
them. Mhm.
>> Um, and I just I what I did notice was
that there were both because the subject
began talking about the sab the Sabbath
>> and the latter portion spoke of him
going to the most holy, him being a high
priest that is not touched by our
infirmities,
>> you know, and it puts together the
sanctuary message with the Sabbath.
>> Okay.
>> And Ellen White's vision came to mind
saying the Sabbath shown in the
sanctuary with the Sabbath glowing,
>> you know. So it just kind of shows that
it was part it was supposed to be part
of our movement that particular ver um
chapter.
>> So I just I guess I kind of wanted to
just highlight get your thoughts as well
as highlight it for everyone. Hebrews 4
is wonderful for preaching the Sabbath.
>> Okay. Thank you very much. God bless
you.
>> Okay. What time is it now? 20 after 5.
>> Okay. I have gotten the 11th
commandment. We have to stop at 5:30.
That's commandment number 11. And that's
from the pastor, my boss. Yes, my good
brother. You're wearing a blue shirt.
That's the color of obedience in the
Bible. God bless you.
>> Praise God. Happy Sabbath, pastor.
>> Happy Sabbath to you.
>> I'm asking a question on behalf of my
father who couldn't be here. I'm reading
from Matthew's 12 and verse 40. And it
says, "For as Jonah was three days and
three nights in the belly of the great
fish,
>> so will the Son of Man be three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth."
Mhm.
>> He would like some clarity on the
context because he knows that Jesus died
on the Sabbath on Friday. He spent three
days, rose again on Sunday, but did not
spend three nights in.
>> Okay, I've heard that all the time.
People want to say Christ died on a
Wednesday. The expression three days and
three nights is a symbolic. It does not
literally mean three full days and three
full nights. It simply requires a part
of three days. So part of the Friday he
was in the tomb part of Saturday the
earliest part of Sunday then he rose.
Once you fulfilled that you fulfilled
three days and three nights. Now Jesus
also said he would rise the third day.
On some occasions he said after three
days other occasions he said the third
day. So he makes both statements but in
the Hebrew mindset three days and three
nights simply a part of each day. And so
if I came to visit you, I'm here today.
Let's say I come to see someone
tomorrow. I spend 2 hours. Did I visit
you on Sunday? Yes. Do I have to say
Sunday morning, Sunday night? No. If I
spent two hours with you on Sunday, I
visited you on Sunday. So three days and
three nights are an expression. All that
needs to be satisfied is a part of each
day. And that fulfills the three days
and three nights. It is not a
mathematical statement. It's a symbolic
statement. Praise God. Thank you for
that. And I just have a quick follow-up
question. Um I'm part of a group of
youth in Claremont, SDA, um 7th Day
Adventist Church. I have a young brother
of mine, Jameson, who didn't want to
stand up to ask this question, but
something that has been perplexing him
and ironically,
>> just ask the question.
>> Is is it a sin for a male to have long
hair?
>> Is it a sin for a man to have long hair?
Well, the Bible says it's a shame for a
man to have long hair.
That's not to teach that a man should
not have long hair. So the Bible
suggests a man should not I think it's 1
Corinthians either 7 or 11. The Bible
suggests a man should not have long
hair.
>> But I'm not here to tell you how long is
long.
>> Yes, sister.
>> Uh am I up next? Okay.
>> I don't know.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, okay. All right. Okay.
>> Now, the sister just mentioned
artificial intelligence
>> and we could take it all the way to the
rule of technocracy.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. where we have databases that are
hard to even imagine the data they will
keep. And then we look at project 2025
and the coming the the coming Sunday law
>> inside that project 2025 and we look at
the news that we
>> hear every day
>> pointing to a globalization
>> of events. How do you personally feel in
2025 about the coming of Christ?
>> What do you mean? How do I personally
feel the coming of Christ?
>> I have my personal feelings about how
soon is.
>> Oh, how soon? Yes.
>> Well, I cannot put a precise date or
when Christ will come, but I believe he
will come in my lifetime.
>> That's the best I can say based on what
I am seeing. Ly tells us just before
Christ comes all the provisions of the
constitution will be laid aside and we
see the movement in that direction. Now
she also says just before Christ comes
or just before probation closes worship
styles in the church will be very very
noisy and we see that all over the
church. And so I this is not a doctrine.
I choose to believe that Jesus Christ's
return is not far off.
>> Amen.
>> One last question from my brother Q.
>> You're the boss. Yes. Um Q, you had
asked
>> who was Q.
>> Prophet come.
>> Um I think it's in Judges. It's uh where
God told one prophet to go on a direct
path. Don't move off it.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And then another prophet
>> invited him
>> and lied and said, "Yeah, God told us."
Why did the prophet that moved off and
went to his house die after? But the one
that lied didn't get punished.
>> I don't know. I don't know. You see,
it's a good question. Now, God gave
specific instructions to the first
prophet. Go on the mission, deliver the
message, and come right back.
No matter what another prophet said, we
must put God's word first above your
father, your mother, your ex-wife, your
wife, your cousin, your boss, God said,
"Go deliver and come right. Don't stop."
He directly violated God's command. God
gave no such command to the second
prophet. Yes, the second prophet lied.
But the first prophet had direct
communication from God.
>> Go on the mission. Do what I say. Come
right back. And he didn't. And God had
to put him to sleep.
>> We don't know what God did to the other
guy. It's not recorded. But that doesn't
justify lying.
Interesting point. God bless you. God
bless you. Okay. Praise God.